let's say that i have a random variable
x which is equal to the number
of dogs that i see in a day and random
variable y is equal to the number
of cats that i see in a day
and let's say i also know what the mean
of each of these random variables are
the expected value so the expected value
of x which i could also denote as the
mean of our random variable x
let's say i expect to see three
dogs a day
and similarly
for the cats
the expected value of y
is equal to i could also denote that as
the mean of y
is going to be equal to and this is just
for the sake of argument let's say i
expect to see four cats a day and in
previous videos we define how do you
take the mean of
the mean of a random variable or the
expected value of a random variable
what we're going to think about now is
what would be the expected value
of x plus y or another way of saying
that the mean
of the sum
of these two random variables
well it turns out and i'm not proving it
just yet that the the mean of the sum of
random variables is equal to the sum of
the means so this is going to be equal
to
the mean of random variable x
plus
the mean of random variable y and so in
this particular case if i were to say
well what's the expected number of dogs
and cats that i would see in a given day
well i would add these two means it
would be three plus four it would be
equal to seven so in this particular
case it's be it is equal to three
plus four
which is equal to which is equal to
seven
and similarly if i were to ask you the
difference if i were to say well what's
the how many more cats in a given day
would i expect to see than dogs so the
expected value of y
minus x
what would that be
well intuitively you might say well hey
if we can add random if the expected
value of the sum is the sum of the
expected values then the expected value
or the mean of the difference will be
the differences of the means and that is
absolutely true so this is the same
thing as the mean of y
minus x
which is equal to the mean of y
is going to be equal to the mean of
y
minus the mean of x
minus the mean of x and in this
particular case it would be equal to 4
minus 3
minus 3 is equal to
1. so another way of thinking about this
intuitively is i would expect to see
on a given day one more cat than dogs
now the example that i've just used this
is discrete random variables on a given
day i wouldn't see 2.2 dogs or pie dogs
the expected value itself does not have
to be a whole number because you could
of course average it over many days but
this same idea that the mean of a sum is
the same thing as the sum of means and
the the mean of a difference of random
variables is the same as the difference
of the means in a future video i'll do a
proof of this